[Music]  are you dating anyone right now I am not  by how times change  Adam rip on is officially off the market  the Olympic figure skater told us in  March he's single  but et can confirm he's in a new  relationship with Finland native Jessie  Pekka the two met on tinder on Monday  the 28 year old shared this shirtless  shot of them together with a caption  good boys finished first riff on who  helped the u.s. win a bronze medal in  the team figure skating competition at  February's Winter Olympics as one of  Team USA's two openly gay male athletes  previously opened up to et about his  dating life and what he's looking for in  a partner  mr. status at this point my status is  single and I mean if you've got a job  and you go to the gym let me know I  guess those standards are I feel like  they could be higher for you you got to  start somewhere you know there any other  qualifications you want to add to that  shortlist no cool I mean am I wrong  [Applause]  you